Hallo ihr Lieben!
Heute gibt's Ofenkartoffeln mit Knoblauch und ich hab mir gedacht:
das ist erstens die perfekte Grillbeilage, zweitens aber auch einfach nur eine Beilage zum Mittagessen
oder drittens einfach nur ein Snack wenn ihr mal wieder Kohldampf habt!
Und jetzt starte ich auch direkt, ich hab jetzt hier meine Kartoffeln,
die hab ich geschält und gewaschen und werd sie jetzt schneiden
in grobe Stücke. Ich möcht sie nicht so klein, sondern ruhig ein bisschen größer,
aber das ist komplett euch überlassen.
So, die Kartoffeln jetzt einfach direkt auf's Backblech geben und dann kommt da Olivenöl dazu,
nehmt da ein gutes kaltgepresstes. Und Kartoffeln mit Olivenöl ist sowieso immer mega lecker!
Und dann gebe ich da auch noch Salz dazu, am besten direkt aus der Mühle.
So und dann mit den Händen schön verteilen.
So, jetzt kommt Knoblauch zum Einsatz. Knoblauch passt ja immer mega, mega gut!
Und diesmal machen wir es so: Wir nehmen uns einen ganzen Bund Knoblauch,
schneiden das hier vorne ab, dann haben wir eine Schnittfläche hier.
Die tunke ich jetzt einmal in etwas Olivenöl und dann nehmt ihr euch einfach Backpapier,
einmal unter den Wasserhahn halten, auswringen - jetzt ist es schön feucht -
und dann wickel ich hier dieses Bund Knoblauch einmal da rein.
Schön umwickeln. Das brauchen wir auch nachher noch, denn das wird im Ofen richtig schön weich.
So und das gebe ich jetzt hier einfach in die Mitte des Backblechs.
Und jetzt habe ich auch schon den Ofen vorgeheizt auf 180° C Ober- und Unterhitze
und dann wird das je nach Größe - wie groß ihr das jetzt hier geschnitten habt - ungefähr 40-50min gar gebacken.
Und dann sehen wir uns nachher wieder!
So, nach dem Backen schnappen wir uns jetzt einen Mörser oder einen feinen Mixer
und geben da frische Petersilie rein
und außerdem die Knoblauchzehen, die jetzt richtig schön weich geworden sind im Backofen.
Und hier riecht's auch schon richtig nach Knoblauch!
So, dann mörsen wir das schön fein und geben anschließend Creme fraiche oder z.B. saure Sahne
oder Joghurt dazu. Und dann ist unser Dip dazu auch schon fertig!
Das heißt ihr habt hier quasi 2 in 1 und könnt's jetzt einfach genießen.
Ich schnapp mir jetzt hier so eine schöne Kartoffel und dippe das hier einmal rein,
und dann probier ich auch gerne einmal für euch weil das auch super lecker ist.
Mmm! Mmm!
Richtig knusprig und köstlich, also macht's unbedingt nach!
Ihr könnt auch gerne den Kanal kostenlos abonnieren, damit ihr nichts mehr verpasst
und dann sehen wir uns ganz bald wieder hier auf meinem Kanal!
Lasst uns gerne in den Kommentaren miteinander schreiben und ja -
bis zum nächsten Mal hier auf Kikis Kitchen!
Tschüss!